good morning nice to see everybody and
thanks for coming through the cold and
through the storms first of all for
those who are arriving from other places
welcome to Yale University and to the
forum on climate change and infectious
disease research I'm mark Pagani and to
the surprise of everyone that knows me
on the director of the Yale climate and
energy institute and by the way we're
hosting this forum and you know we're
very excited about this this is
something we've been thinking about for
some time trying to integrate and bring
together climate scientists and human
health scientists particularly in the
field of infectious disease this is
something we we feel that is is
underappreciated particularly in the
United States the climate scientists
that I work with I think and many of
those in the audience have a pretty good
appreciation of the coming changes in
temperature and the water cycle and
seasonality and it just just seems
obvious that this is going to impact the
underlying ecology of organisms that
make you sick and the end and the
organism sent transmitted that disease
you know and maybe I'm wrong and maybe
nothing will happen but we simply don't
know and it's sort of shocking how how
underfunded this this topic is through
it funding agencies like NIH and NSF and
without that funding really the
exploration of the topic is is severely
compromised and so one of the outcomes
of this sort of meeting and hopefully
meetings in the future will be to try to
transform that at funding scenario so
we're looking forward to the ideas at
you know emerge from this forum and
hopefully collaborations
and that will proceed into tomorrow as
well I want to stress that that this
forum took a bit of time to pull
together and I don't want to thank the
organizers of the of the event and those
include Maria Dirk Vassar from the
school of public health maybe comes
raise your hand so people can see who
you are and true dia sterols mo from the
department of geology and geophysics
duraline fish from school of public
health and an hour student intern
Rihanna DeBartolo court of honor and
that's all I have to say and I hope you
enjoyed the meeting and your stay at in
New Haven our first talk unless it
started is no a different Balfour is
assistant professor from the Department
environmental Earth System science and
Stanford University you know I thank you
everyone and thanks the organizers for
having me out and hosting this thanks to
to mark for the support I this is this
is an area i really want to echo marks
statements about about the importance of
the area and and opportunities for for
new exploration it's it's an area that i
have i have a bit of funding from NIH
which is i put all that all the
important parts of the presentation or
right at the bottom so maybe a pointer
here okay here we go so most that will
be hidden throughout the talk but i do
have a little bit of funding from nih
and actually just in the airport on the
way on the way here you know emails are
flying on some of that project we're
trying to get set up that will i'll talk
about a little bit at the end but i
think for me this is this is a really
exciting workshop because i feel very
genuinely that that I
I have a lot to learn and this is this
seems like a great opportunity to do it
so I my the title here the possible
relevance is really is is very sincere
it's may not be relevant we'll see but
it's I think it's an exciting area
that's that's emerging in terms of
climate disease relationships alright so
I wanna just real quick acknowledge my
numbers my research group and in
particular Daniel Horton who's who's
working on this NIH work whose postdoc
I'm Martin share whose research staff
has done a lot of helps a lot of the GCM
analyses that you'll see and these are
collaborators on to NIH funded projects
I'll show some I'll talk a little bit at
the end about the one project with with
Marco Patrick and Laura Kramer and
Jordan is a is a graduate student with
marm and Dan as I mentioned and then we
also have a project with Karen levy
that's focused on more on the on the
hydrologic cycle and hydrologic extremes
but since this is the temperature talk
I'll focus on the on the temperature
work at the end so the the the work
that's going on in my group is mostly
focused around trying to understand the
interface between physical climate
processes and climate impacts so we're
trying to identify the phenomena the
physical climate phenomenon that most
directly and acutely impact natural and
human systems and then we're trying to
work from that Matt middle that
interface out in both directions to try
to understand the physical climate
dynamics that shape those those climate
phenomena and also understand the
vulnerability of different natural and
human systems to to those physical
climate dynamics potential changes in
those physical context so
health and and and infectious diseases
more more specifically our and
interesting and potentially very
fruitful candidate for for studying this
interface and and you know what I'll
actually actually show some work that's
that's focused on corn and not not
because I'm going to argue that that
people might get infectious diseases
from Cornell that maybe that's possible
I would be excited to shout now if if
that's possible but more just to just to
highlight kind of how how how we can go
about using biological sensitivity to
two different climate conditions to to
understand potential climate change
impacts when we have those when we have
an understanding of those of those
relationships which I think we we maybe
have more so for corn than then for some
infectious diseases alright so I I never
know which room I'm walking into when I
give a talk so just a couple of real
quick kind of you know atmosphere ocean
climate dynamics 101 slides these are
from Marshall and plum but you know that
the climate and and weather conditions
that we experience or a result of the
energy balance of the planet and really
the the imbalance of energy across the
planet and and because of Earth's shape
and and the tilt of its of its axis of
rotation the amount of energy coming
into the system is not uniform at
different latitudes at nor nor
throughout the year and as a result
there is excess of net radiation in the
tropics the deficit at the higher
latitudes and what we experience on a
day-to-day basis in in terms of the mean
witch in Palo Alto its kind of always
like the mean but in some other places
it's you know it varies quite a bit and
both the mean and the extremes of
climate our result of this energy
imbalance and from time to time there
are really extreme events and you can
see over here on the black border of the
screen these are temperature anomalies
from july two thousand and three in
Europe up to on the order of 10 degree
temperature anomalies this was a this
was a certainly a 1 in 500 year event in
terms of the the temperature the direct
temperature record in Europe in parts of
Europe and it's been argued that it was
a one-in-a-million year event
statistically that certainly the summer
temperature in much of Europe was was on
the order of 5 Sigma removed from the
mean and this is this was an extreme
event statistically and it had it was
also a severe event in terms of the
impact and depending on on who's doing
the calculation and in what manner on
the order of 50,000 deaths associated
with this with this heat wave so this is
one example where oh it's moving thank
you this is one example where you know
these the the these physical processes
in the atmosphere ocean a couple couple
climate system can have very very acute
impacts even on on very short time
scales and you know I talked about the
energy balance of the planet and the
reality is that we are we are altering
the the energy balance of the planet and
one of the primary ways is that we are
altering the energy balances through the
emission of greenhouse gases to the
atmosphere including carbon dioxide and
this is the Keeling curve which was
which I'm imagine it most in the room or
familiar and so you know we want to
understand what happens to the climate
system as a result of this change in
radiative forcing the change in the
energy input to the system we want to
understand how the physical processes in
the climate system respond and and we
all we want to understand what the
what's possible impacts could be as was
stated in the introduction
so what I'd like to do is take a look at
that interface between physical
processes such as what what made the
2003 heat wave those kinds of events at
different levels of forcing and try to
understand you use the vulnerability of
natural and human systems to try to
identify processes of interest just skip
over this alright so the first question
I'd like to address real quick is or
we'll see how quickly eyes is how my
global warming influence temperature
extremes and this is a figure from
diffenbaugh and share that came out in
2011 and there have been other other
versions of this this kind of analysis
published elsewhere and what this is
showing is the percentage of seasons
that exceed the late 20th century
maximum so if this is this a simply
accounting exercise if we look at the
late 20th century and we count up I'm
sorry we find we find the hottest season
whether it's December January February
or June July August we find in each
location the the hottest year hottest
season that occurred and then we look
forward in a suite of global climate
model experiments and just ask in each
year was djf warmer or colder than that
late 20th century maximum if warmer than
plus one and we just we just count them
up and you can see that by the late
twenty-first century in this a 1 B
scenario and we can talk about those
scenarios separately if people
interested but I that that by by the
late 20th century at around in this case
around a little bit over six hundred
parts per million co2 in the tropics
between 90 and a hundred percent of of
the seasons are exceeding that late 20th
century maximum and enlarge
large areas of the globe something like
three quarters of the of the seasons are
exceeding that late 20th century maximum
and so given given the magnitude of
these changes we were interested to look
at the time of emergence of this
unprecedented heat right if every if
every season is above the late 20th
century maximum how how quickly might
that emerged in different parts of the
globe and so this is this is just an
example of analysis for one grid point
good point near powell also inspired by
Shara dolls good point near zurich for
those who know the 2004 paper on the
european heat wave so this is just just
what we do at each grid point we can
look at the time series we have all
these realizations that have been
donated to the to the international
community by climate modelling groups
from around the world in the CNF archive
each of those black lines is different
realizations at different realization
and we can what we're going to ask here
is at what point is there never a season
cooler than the late 20th century
maximum right and so this the red line
here is the first of all these
realizations the red line is the has the
earliest permanent exceedance right so
around 20 22 or something like that here
this red line this this realization
ceases to ever go below you know for
that for for the summer let's say this
is JJ ceases to ever go below the late
20th century maximum and this is an
ensemble they're all getting the same
radiative forcing but there there's
noise in the system there's differences
in how the models are constructed so
there's a spread there's an uncertainty
in that permanent emergence and this
blue realization is shows the last
that's the latest permanent emergence in
in the all the way out and in fact
doesn't does not emerge in late 20th
century and the yellow is is the meeting
so there's a distribution we can
calculate we can calculate the
distribution of the dates of the that
last that last occurrence below the late
20th century maximum which we call the
permanent exceedance the date of
permanence
and if we look at this in Matthew this
is the the top row ignore that so this
is the decade last occurrence in the
season that's cooler than the 19 80 92
99 Maxim and I'm showing the median here
so that yellow line and in the
supplementary of the paper we show we
show the earliest in the latest 25th and
75th percentile but what you see first
at least what I see first is all of this
dark purple bill I don't know if it
looks purple or not but we bill an eye
on the way we're talking about color
scales and and visual perception looks
purple to me so what this is saying is
that there's a 50-percent likelihood in
this ensemble that these purple areas
within the next two decades will will
emerge entirely from the late 20th
century temperature distribution in
terms of the seasonal temperature right
so that never again there's a 50-percent
likelihood that that these areas will
never again experience a season below
the late 20th century maximum which was
much earlier than I expected and you
know i think this raises the question of
you know what is a big change in actual
this is what it was really mail email in
the airport when I got off the plane
last night or collaborators were we're
setting up some incubation experiments
at all that I'll mention at the end and
and you know they were saying that the
cement five the client model ensemble
doesn't simply simulate temperature
changes that are big enough and because
it's only you know a couple of degrees
in the tropics and you know what is big
enough compared to zero Kelvin a couple
degrees is not very big but compared to
the envelope of variability that natural
and human systems have experienced over
recent decades moving entirely out of
that envelope is big regardless of how
many degrees that is so to me this is
striking I wouldn't say it's alarming
but it's certainly striking and we can
ask we can
ask how quickly might this immersion in
different regions and what's the
distribution of that timing and what I'd
like to focus on now I think is that is
the bottom panel here and this is the
this is the historical period and what
we've we've done is we've asked so we're
looking in the future from what I've
showed you were looking these future
climate simulations and we've compared
those future simulations with the late
20th century and if we wanted to ask has
this emergence already been observed is
it already happening is this can we can
we test a hypothesis about the the
greenhouse gas increases that have
already occurred and it's if you're
looking at this absolute threshold of
the the hottest summer of the late 20th
century then it's a tough question to
ask about the late 20th century so we
don't really have a distribution of
exceedances of the maximum so what we've
done is we've just moved the window
backwards we've said if the mid 20th
century was the baseline and then we
look at the at the late 20th century has
it has this emergence occurred so what
you're seeing is in each of these
regions is the time series of of the
percent of the area in the region that
that exceeds the mid 20th century
maximum and the purple lines here are
are the observations with the the raw
observations being in the lighter purple
and the attending running mean being in
the darker purple and then each grade ah
tis an individual climate model
realization and the black the black and
red lines show the various various means
of both the mean the black is the mean
across the realizations and then the the
red is the tenure running mean of that
ensemble mean and what you see is that
in in the tropics there's there's been a
very clear and substantial emergence of
unprecedented heat so the late 20th
century is is has become considerably
more room
moved from from the mid 20th century and
that in the in some of the mid latitude
regions that's occurred such as in the
Mediterranean but in in other mid
latitude regions it is not as not as
clear and North America is another look
looks a bit like like China I'm not
showing it on this on this figure and we
can ask about statistical significance
and and other other measures of that we
can talk about that so what this is
indicating is that not only is it is it
likely from a statistical point of view
in terms of the climate model ensemble
that this emergence will will will occur
over the next few decades in large areas
of the globe with increasing global
warming but also that it has already
emerged relative to the earlier part of
the 20th century and for many for many
reasons particularly in the tropics and
will so we might ask how much global
warming and that that dark purple in the
map was was prior to the year twenty
forty four for that fifty percent
likelihood and if we look in the
scenario that's forcing these climate
model simulations what we see is that if
we look out over the next three decades
for 20 40 that's a less than a degree
and a half of warming above the late
20th century baseline which puts this
level of global warming right around
that two degrees Celsius above the
pre-industrial that that is in the
Copenhagen Accord so even within that
global warming target if even if the
international community were to achieve
a limit on global warming of two degrees
c above the pre-industrial baseline then
these climate model simulations are
suggesting that that we're still likely
to see emergence of a permanent
unprecedented heat regime over large
areas of the globe particularly in the
tropics where the interannual
variability is much less than than in
the higher latitudes which is really the
cause of that it's not the magnitude of
warming in the tropics that's causing
that early emerge
it's really the variability variability
being low all right so um that's kind of
the global climate part of the talk and
bill and maybe others will pick up with
some other some other aspects of the
global climate model analysis later in
the sessions the these are pretty these
are pretty the global models are pretty
coarse scale couple degrees getting down
to one degree or so in the ensemble that
I showed certainly there are higher
resolution global simulations that are
appearing now but if we really want to
understand the impacts of climate change
much of those impacts will be felt it at
local scales and will result from from
local scale changes in order resolve
those processes that create local scale
climate variability we need higher
resolution models than what's available
in the current generation of global
climate models and there are a number of
people in the room who work on various
forms of various approaches to trying to
trying to get more regional and local
detail this is just a cartoon showing
how we can nest progressively higher
resolution models can be me atmospheric
amine the ocean could be involved and
most of all I'll show for the rest of
talk is is using hydrostatic nesting a
25 kilometer or so grid spacing in the
atmosphere over various parts of the
world we're also including with with
some of this NIH funding trying to get
down to non hydrostatic scales where we
can or permit convection in the
atmosphere we can we can talk about
those details to anyone's interested the
other the other frontier which I won't
talk about the details of but I think is
important for the discussion of scale
which I know will continue to come up
throughout the day is the variable
resolution global global modeling which
is a number of groups are pushing on
this frontier and I'm involved in one of
those efforts with with Los Alamos and
in car to rather the nesting to have
a you know a variable resolution in the
atmosphere at the main point here is
that we wanna if we want to understand
you know the scale that say a mosquito
feels the climate system we need to get
down to much finer finer scales than the
current generation of global climate
models so back to this this hottest
season metric that you've already heard
about getting getting from from the
global climate model scale that I've
already showed you to 25 kilometers
substantially improves this spatial
pattern of the magnitude of that event
so that the the GCMs that I already
showed you here's the this is the
magnitude of the hottest season over the
second half of the 20th century the
colors are almost useless without the
scale but red is hotter blue is cooler
and this is a the crew is it 11
observational data set so just the same
metric in that half degree observational
data set relative to the global models
and then our nested climate model
simulations are in the in the middle and
as you'd expect just from resolving a
topography better we better resolve the
the spatial variation in in this metric
and this is temperature but this is true
for a whole suite of of climate
phenomena particularly extremes and it's
and it's not just in areas of complex
topography so if we focus in a bit on
the on the US and this is again just the
counting exercise of how many how many
seasons exceed the sorry in this case
how many days exceed exceeds some
temperature threshold in this case this
is getting down to the daily scale so
this is a 95th percentile daily maximum
event there are 365 days in most years
so just by definition this is about the
18th hottest day of the year from year
to year and you can see that by this
decade of the 2030s around that two
degrees warming target in the Copenhagen
agreement
areas of the US are seeing either a
doubling or even a tripling of the
occurrence of the that 18th oddest day
of the year so as as one blogger put it
you know in i think it was in it was in
response to a to a figure that where the
it was further out in the century and
arizona you know was like 90 90 days a
year on on the map and and and i had
made a statement in the in the press
like something like well this is like
phoenix getting you know ninety days of
the hottest two weeks of the year and
one blogger responded saying well in my
opinion phoenix already gets three
months of the hottest two weeks the year
but that's basically what it is right i
mean so even you know this is 60 days
this is more than a doubling of that of
that threshold just with with one degree
of global warming and what we're
interested in as i as i mentioned is
that are the physical climate processes
that shape shape these these changes in
the impacts relevant climate phenomena
and what we're seeing here is the
anomalies in in amis eric circulation
the precipitation the soil moisture in
the evapotranspiration and this is
expressed as the decade of the 2030s in
our high resolution climate model
ensemble minus the late 20th century so
brown is drier less precipitation less
soil moisture less evapotranspiration
and these are these are changes in in
the summer mean fields but they're very
reminiscent of what we see during heat
wave events and actually if you look at
say 2000 the Summoner 2012 that happened
in the US these these anomalies are very
similar to what what occurs and there's
been a lot of papers studying
mid-latitude heat waves and this is anti
cyclonic circulation anomaly drier soils
less evapotranspiration less
precipitation very consistent physically
with what we see during heat waves and
what what the climate model is
simulating is a shift of the summer mean
towards this heat wave heat wave like
conditions and the the so in this case
global warming you know the increase in
greenhouse gas concentrations it's
causing global warming is really really
giving kind of causing it giving a
triple a triple whammy to the surface
climate so there's the there's the
increasing long wave radiation from from
more co2 and other greenhouse gas
molecules in the atmosphere but there
are two other boosts to the to the
surface energy balance one is that the
decrease in evapotranspiration from the
drier soils and less precipitation that
that decreases the latent heat flux and
partitions the the surface energy
balance towards sensible heat flux so
the that surface moisture response where
there's less energy going into
evaporating water because the water is
not in the soils that that's a second
whammy in addition to the long-wave
forcing and then there's actually a
third which is that none of the
stabilization of the atmosphere is
associated with this anti cyclonic
circulation anomaly tends to create more
clear sky conditions less cloud cover
and greater penetration of solar
radiation to the surface and we see that
in in the incident shortwave flux over
the over the central and eastern US so
there are really these in addition just
to the to the global warming the
regional atmospheric dynamics are
changing in a way that amplifies the
effect of the increasing co2 so it's
really not just this shift in the if we
get two degrees of global warming that
we're going to get two degrees of
regional local warming everywhere as
well what really matters is the response
of the of the climate dynamics and if we
look out further in the in the century
if we could send these these these co2
forcing experiments out beyond this near
term period look all the way in this a 1
B scenario all the way out to you know
above 600 parts per million co2 we see
that this this change in the surface
energy balance intensifies with
increasing co2 concentrations so the
upper left is precipitation and you can
see the shift towards progressively not
only warmer conditions
the surface but also progressively drier
conditions and what you're seeing here
is each we have we have five ensemble
members in our 25 kilometer simulations
so each decade has actually 50 years
because we're running it five times with
the same forcing so you have 50 dots in
each of these colors in each color is it
is a decade so again intensifying
decreases in precipitation over the
central us intensifying decreases in
soil moisture intensifying decreases in
evapotranspiration intensifying
increases in the incident shortwave
flocks and in fact for many of these
variables by the last decade of the 20th
century oh sorry the 21st century the
last 50 years in our in our ensemble
50-year population see that almost all
of the years are are either above or
below that that zero line depending on
the variable right so almost all of the
years are are beyond the mean and so
this question of the new normal becomes
becomes relevant and if we go back back
to Europe we've done similar analyses
and other in other parts of the world
and certainly in the mid-latitudes this
is a robust response with with the
surface amplification of the of the
greenhouse forcing via via surface
drying in the mid-latitudes you see very
similar responses in europe with with
the change in soil moisture and
evapotranspiration that amplifies
amplifies the response of extreme
temperatures to to global warming so in
the upper left is the is the 95th
percentile maximum and this time it's
the magnitude so the the that that 18th
atif day of the year is warming by 7 to
9 degrees over over parts of Europe in
the in the late twenty-first century in
these simulations and it's highly
correlated spatially with this with the
surface drawing and we can actually go
back to that that 2003 heat wave and ask
how often do those conditions that
occurred in the 2003 heat wave occur in
the late twenty-first century climate
with with in this case with with
basically business as usual or actually
now now that that Davis at all wedges
paper is out maybe it's it's less than
business as usual emissions but in this
case it's the a2 scenario for those that
are familiar but if we if we take the
analyses of excess deaths that have been
published so this is a this is a paper
that came out in 2005 and this is
mortality on the vertical axis in France
and and temperature on the right on the
vertical axis and the right with the
with the the line the line plots being
being maximum minimum temperature and
during this period of peak excess death
the the maximum temperature stayed
around 35 degrees c and the minimum
temperatures stayed around 19 degrees c
or so during that period and that's when
the peak excess deaths occurred so we
can just do the counting exercise again
and ask how many days out of the year is
the maximum temperature above 35 °c and
and how many days out here is above the
minimum temperature above 20 degrees c
and what you see for for France for
example is these are on the order of 20
to 25 in some cases even 30 days per
year that this unprecedented severe heat
wave occurs in the future climate so
this is essentially a 2003 heat wave
occurring every year two weeks three
weeks in some cases even four weeks a
year on average so a very different
climate that if we look at the response
of human health that kind of event in
the recent path potentially could have
impacts alright so I want to I'm on my
last few minutes here and my last few
slides so that's a good coincidence so
that you know the title is the title of
the workshop is infectious diseases and
and I'm interested to learn how what
I've already showed could be could be
relevant for infectious diseases it
might not be at all it might just be
relevant for it being really hot for
people but we do have there are some
we do it we do have some work going this
targeted more specifically infectious
disease diseases and I want to give just
a brief a brief story about corn and
then a brief one one or two slides on
what we're doing to try to understand
fundamental relationships between
between temperature and and disease
vectors so the relationships between
corn yields and temperature have been
very rigorously studied particularly
United States but elsewhere as well and
this is a one of those studies that's
from shelling corn Roberts which is not
present on the screen shanker and
Roberts in 2009 and they've taken all
the you know corneal data from counties
in the US and taken temperature and
precipitation data and and done a
performed regression analysis and what
they find is that there's this very
nonlinear or steep nonlinear
relationship with severe heat so that
are not in a relationship with
increasing heat accumulation I should
say so at low to intermediate levels of
heat accumulation corn yields increase
there's a positive relationship we know
this already right the Corn Belt is is
not in fact in the Arctic alright it's
in it's in the central us for a number
of reasons but part of it is the
temperature but at high high levels of
heat accumulation there's a very steep
decline in in corneal zand and the
physiological reasons for this have
actually been been studied for a long
time with with lab experiments and what
I'm going to talk about the corn for a
couple of slides and then you know you
can start imagining now or afterwards
I'll ask you to imagine just that it's
not corn and it says something it could
be something different right it could be
some other system for which the the
relationship with climate is known and
there have been they're having some
studies on you know different different
types of insects and mosquitoes and and
other other potentially relevant biota
so this is the relationship for corn and
we can we can take these climate model
simulations that I've already shown
you and basically run the regression
with the climate of the past in the
simulations and the climate of the
future and what we find when we do that
is that there's there's little response
to this there's little there's there's
little change in the good heat over the
central us over the next three decades
basically the mean shifts so that the
cooler partier becomes warmer the warm
part of the year becomes warmer and the
mean good heat remains the same amount
of good heat remains the same but
there's a substantial increase in the
negative heat accumulation over the next
three decades and that causes a increase
in both the mean of negative heat
accumulation and meaning detrimental
heat accumulation to be more precise and
the variability of detrimental heat
accumulation so you can see that
Illinois for example starts to look
something like Oklahoma does it present
in terms of the the negative heat and so
we can ask using these using these
climate model simulations we can ask a
couple of questions that are that are
highly relevant for corn and I think
could be relevant for this question of
changes in range of say disease vectors
for example so one is we can ask what
level of adaptation is required to
offset the climate change so we can just
look at the terms in that regression
both that critical temperature at which
the negative that steep decline in
yields occurs we can ask what if we move
that what if there's some adaptation
that increases heat tolerance by causing
the negative the negative yields to
occur at 30 degrees instead of 29 31 32
33 34 right we can move that critical
threshold we can also ask how steep is
that decline right if if there's some
adaptation that causes the the negative
effect of temperature to be less severe
lessens the slope of that decline then
how much how much decline in that in
that slope is required that's the this
is the current data the current slope is
1 and then just fractions of that of
that beta and we can ask
for the current what how much adaptation
is it take to get back to that current
value the other question that we can ask
is the spatial adaptation so where does
the current climate occur in the future
and I was already mentioning that
there's very little change in the in the
good the mean good heat accumulation so
that that area actually falls right over
the Corn Belt in the future but what
you'll find is that if we look at the
negative heat the bad heat least the
heat that cause negative yields and both
the mean and the variability that the
future climate actually isn't doesn't
have an analog to the current climate
right so that space those different
variables sorry separate in space so if
you if you go to find the same the area
of of mean above the the negative heat
threshold you'll find a different area
than if you look at the variability of
temperature above the negative threshold
right so there's we could imagine doing
this kind of analysis with some other
temperature relationships that maybe is
more appropriate for a mosquito or a
virus or some other something else of
relevance for disease alright so lastly
what are we what do we were trying we're
actually trying to do that now in in one
of the NIH funded projects but the
problem is that we lack the fundamental
leaf the group of us that are funded
maybe others don't lack it but we lack
the fundamental understanding of the
relationships between temperature and
the the vector biology the vector
ecology and the virus virus response to
temperature as well so we're setting up
some a number of lab experiments to try
to study these and and the hook here is
that we're using climate model output to
generate the temperature regime that
that it's going into the incubation so
rather than just adding two degrees or
adding three degrees or adding four
degrees we're analyzing the climate
model output to say what is the
distribution of daily temperatures over
over these climate model simulations and
can we can we use those to have a
physically
physically consistent climate change
that we're exposing the in this case the
mosquitoes two and one of the challenges
there is we're trying to prescribe 70 80
90 100 years of climate change within an
incubation experiment so there's there's
some real challenges of how you how you
get there from here other than waiting
for 70 years so I'm eager to talk to
people about that so just a couple of
figures to close from poster that Dan
Horton had at age you this just in
December so basically we're looking
across the climate model ensemble each
these decadal periods and we're
prescribing we're basically going to run
a year long incubation experiment a year
of the real calendar and we're going to
try to prescribe this distribution of
climate change that occurs over the next
70 years right so we're we're basically
chopping up the real calendar in two
decades so you get a couple weeks if
you're going to do 60 or 70 years a year
you get a couple couple weeks / /
decades so we're going to look at we're
taking the distribution of temperature
change across that in each of those
decades and then we can take the PDF and
draw from the PDF of daily temperatures
to generate a one year long in terms of
the real calendar time series that gets
us both from the present to 2060 or 2070
but also gives us the physically
consistent response of daily
temperatures that's that's simulated in
the climate models all right so I'll
close with the conclusion slide up and
just say that again that I think this is
a really exciting fertile area of
research in terms of understanding not
only the impacts of climate change but
also the physical dynamics of climate
change I think we can just like with
corn and with other impacts I think we
can use disease as a probe for
understanding understanding the physical
response of the climate system to global
warming and in many cases maybe we
already know enough about the about the
fundamental relationships but I think in
a lot of cases as was mentioned in the
introduction we need we need work at the
very you know in the lab and in the
field with you know without with that
before we go into the
feature it with with projections of
impact so thank you very much for your
patience and I'm happy to take questions
as there's time